[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit Gundula
Gause und Dunja Hayali
schönen guten Abend Nancy fazer hat
Probleme böse Zungen sagen Nancy fazer
ist das Problem versteht die
Innenministerin steht aus
unterschiedlichen Gründen unter Druck
das eine Thema ist die Migration bei dem
zum Beispiel überforderte Kommunen sich
von der Innenministerin allein gelassen
fühlen und das andere Thema da fühlen
sich diverse Mitglieder des
Innenausschusses allein gelassen denn
Phaser tauchte zweimal nicht auf um sich
zur Causa schönbomben zu äußern also zu
ihrer umstrittenen Abberufung des
ehemaligen Chefs des Bundesamtes für
Sicherheit in der Informationstechnik
die bisher genannten Gründe dafür die
wirken eher die Fuß bis unklar
vielleicht sind ja aber aller guten
Dinge drei denn heute war sie dann doch
endlich im Innenausschuss und dann hier
bei uns im Interview hat der
Befreiungsschlag funktioniert Klaus
Brodbeck es gibt Tage im Berufsleben von
Politikern der kommt irgendwie alles
zusammen Nancy Feser heute morgen
Innenausschuss es geht um die Versetzung
des ehemaligen bsi-chefs Arne Schönbohm
und den laut vorgetragenen Verdacht der
Opposition die Ministerin habe dazu
möglicherweise den Verfassungsschutz
durch Nachfragen instrumentalisieren
wollen Phaser weiß das zurück das
Bundesministerium hat Ende Oktober 2022
beim
Bundes-
dies war die einzige Anfrage beim
Bundesamt für Verfassungsschutz und es
gab auch keinerlei Anweisung von mir
eine zweite durchzuführen der Präsident
des Verfassungsschutzes bestätigt eine
Anfrage keine Nachfrage das war's nach
Oktober 22 hat es weder von Frau
Ministerin Feser noch von anderen
Mitarbeitenden im Bundesministerium des
Innern noch mal anfragen in diese
Richtung anders Bundesamt gegeben weder
ausdrücklich noch augenzwinkernd noch
auf untersten Ebenen zu beobachten die
Union im Rückwärtsgang es ging zu keinem
Zeitpunkt
von mir oder unserer Fraktion gab es die
Behauptung dass das Bundesamt für
Verfassungsschutz in irgendeiner Form
rechtswidrig gehandelt hätte wir hatten
nicht den geringsten Verdacht und die
Vermutung dass hier im Amt selbst
entsprechend gehandelt würde da konnte
man tatsächlich dann mal die Frage
stellen warum ist jetzt sozusagen zu
diesem Zeitpunkt eigentlich diese causa
ein so relevanter Vorgang und dann also
jetzt hier ohne irgendwie jemanden zu
explodieren von irgendwas dann könnte
man schon auf den Gedanken kommen dass
der hessische Landtagswahlkampf damit
irgendwie auch zusammenhängt auch in
Bayern ist Wahlkampf der
Ministerpräsident besucht die bayerische
Grenzpolizei es geht um Migration und
Markus Söder wäre nicht Markus Süder
käme da nicht eine Spitze gegen Berlin
ich glaube das entwickelt sich zu einem
echten Problem für Deutschland deswegen
musste der Bundeskanzler jetzt
eingreifen und muss zur
Migrationspolitik auch was sagen Frau
Feser ist meiner Meinung nach komplette
Verfahren die Innenministerin bleibt
unter Druck regierungsbefragung
dominiert von steigenden Zahlen
geflüchteter im Land man werden sie zum
Schutz auch unserer Kommunen aber auch
des Landes dafür sorgen dass die
unkontrollierte Einwanderung an den
Grenzen gedämmt wird dass dort
kontrolliert wird deshalb bedeutet der
Verzicht auf Grenzkontrollen definitiv
den Verzicht auf eine effektive
Bekämpfung illegaler einreisen so kommt
vieles zusammen für Nancy fazer an
diesem Tag und noch ist er nicht vorbei
einige Fragen konnten heute geklärt
werden andere nicht das versuchen wir
jetzt mit der Innenministerin und damit
einen schönen guten Abend Frau Feser
nach Berlin schönen guten Abend Frau
Hayali wieso haben Sie Arne schönbuhm im
Oktober eigentlich abgesetzt bevor seine
Überprüfung im April abgeschlossen war
also wir haben im Oktober
deshalb diese Entscheidung getroffen ich
hatte Vertrauensverlust und das kam zum
einen daher dass ich fachlich in der
Frage wie Cyberangriffe durch die
russische Bedrohung zu beurteilen sind
aber auch gab es schon Zweifel bei
meinen Vorgängern an der Amtsführung an
der Spitze des BSI und dann traf mich in
dieser Zeit eine sehr breite
Berichterstattung über auch Nähe
kennverhältnisse von in seinem Umfeld
nach Russland und an einer solchen
Behörde muss man ja besonders sicher und
viel Vertrauen haben ob jemand dort noch
bleiben kann ich hätte diesen
Vertrauensverlust und dann hatte eine
schöne Wohnung ja gebeten dass
Disziplinarverfahren gegen sich selber
einzuleiten bleiben wir mal bei diesem
öffentlichen Eindruck ihr Parteifreund
und Vorsitzender im Innenausschuss sagte
hier vor kurzem im heute journal das
durch die Böhmermann Sendung der
Eindruck in der Öffentlichkeit
entstanden sein man könne schön Bogen
nicht vertrauen und das könnten sie sich
als Ministerin nicht erlauben das heißt
die öffentliche Meinung macht ihre
Personalpolitik nein auf keinen Fall
deswegen habe ich gerade gesagt es gab
vorher schon fachliche Zweifel die meine
Vorgänger auch schon hatten da hatte die
Fachaufsicht schon mehrfach reagiert und
in dieser Zeit als ich mir nicht immer
einig war über die Frage wie die
cyber-eingriffe aus Russland
einzuschätzen sind traf mich eine sehr
breite Berichterstattung nicht nur von
Herrn Böhmermann es gab auch Berichte in
der Zeit bei ARD und dann habe ich
darüber noch mal nachgedacht und es ist
einfach ein großer Vertrauensverlust
eingetreten und das darf bei einer so
sicheren Sicherheitsbehörde nicht sein
ja aber aus dem Innenministerium hieß es
dann kurz nach der Sendung dass
notwendige Vertrauen der Öffentlichkeit
in die Neutralität und Unparteilichkeit
sei nicht mehr gegeben also die
Öffentlichkeit die Bürger die kannten
vor der böhmermann-sendung ich will
jetzt hier niemanden zu nahe treten aber
das BSI wahrscheinlich gar nicht das
heißt sie haben doch auf öffentliche
Meinung und öffentliche Vorwürfe re
agiert nein ich kann sie noch mal sagen
ein drittes Mal für mich gab es
fachliche Gründe zum einen ähm die ja
auch schon meine Vorgänger hatten da hat
die Fachaufsicht schon paar mal
eingegriffen und es ging noch mal in
einer Zeit ähm Russlands furchtbarer
Angriff gegen die Ukraine um neue Cyber
Bedrohung und da habe ich entschieden
als es eine sehr breite
Berichterstattung gab das ist nicht mehr
dass er nicht mehr mein Vertrauen hat
jetzt ist es ja so dass dieses Thema
schon sehr lange auch öffentlich
diskutiert wird das hätten sie natürlich
verhindern können indem sie etwas eher
in den Innenausschuss gegangen wären man
sagt ganz oft Politiker stolpern nicht
über den Fehler sondern eher über den
Umgang haben sie sich irgendwas
vorzuwerfen in der Causa schönbrunnen
ich habe mir gar nichts vorzuwerfen und
was den letzten Innenausschuss vor zwei
Wochen betrifft habe ich mich heute bei
den Parlamentariern für entschuldigt
dass ich nicht da war ich war damals
sauer dass so viel Unwahrheiten in der
Öffentlichkeit behauptet wurden dann
hatte mich dann entschieden lieber im
Deutschen Bundestag dazu zu reden und
die hauptvorwürfe auszuräumen apropos
Fehler sie sind ja auch
Spitzenkandidatin in Hessen in ihrem
Wahlprogramm stand da zunächst alle
Menschen die länger als sechs Monate
hier leben sollen das kommunale
Wahlrecht in Hessen erhalten jetzt heißt
es das war eine Panne
das sollte eigentlich sechs Jahre lauten
das passieren das ist ein
Übertragungsfehler gewesen ich glaube
sowas kann passieren der CDU ist es
heute auch passiert indem Sie Bilder aus
tiefes genommen hat und nicht den
Deutschen Bundestag in einem Werbevideo
ich glaube das kann überall passieren
ich glaube aber das vieles thematisiert
wird gerade weil in zweieinhalb Wochen
die Wahl in Hessen ist
gut das sagen sie auch immer wieder dass
vieles thematisiert wird aber die Fragen
stellen sich ja nun mal Wahlkampf hin
oder her und wenn wir schon beim Thema
Migration sind an den großen
Stellschrauben beim Thema Migration klar
da dreht die EU bis die neuen Beschlüsse
wirken da gibt es ja einige wenn sie
denn wirken das dauert ein bisschen die
Zeit haben aber die Kommunen hier bei
uns in Deutschland nicht
Belastungsgrenze erreicht sagt selbst
der Bundespräsident und auch
Ex-Bundespräsident Gauck findet die
Begrenzung von Zuwanderung nicht
verwerflich und viele Kommunen
unterstützen daher jetzt auch den
Vorschlag von Markus Söder den MP aus
Bayern mit einer Obergrenze sind sie da
gesprächsbereit ich bin immer
gesprächsbereit das sollte man in einer
Demokratie sowieso sein aber ich will es
noch mal sagen da wird etwas so geriert
aus Bayern gerade da ist ja auch
zufällig am 8 Oktober Wahlkampf man
könnte das alleine regeln in Deutschland
mit einer Obergrenze wo setzen Sie die
an wenn die Studentin aus dem Iran kommt
die 2010 das geht gar nicht sie sind den
internationalen Verpflichtungen
unterliegen der Genfer Menschen
Flüchtlingskonvention also das heißt wir
haben ja auch unsere Verpflichtungen zu
erfüllen und ja auf der einen Seite ist
es wichtig was ich erreichen konnte in
Europa nämlich mit einer Einigung über
ein gemeinsames Asylsystem auf der
anderen Seite habe ich die Grenzen zu
Tschechien Polen jetzt noch mal mit sehr
viel Bundespolizei verstärkt wir machen
Schleierfahndung um an den Grenzen
irreguläre Migration auch zu verhindern
und eins ist klar wir brauchen eine
bessere solidarische Verteilung
innerhalb Europas wenn Sie das gerade
mit der Schleierfahndung ansprechen dass
sie ein spannenderer ein spannender
Punkt ein anderer Vorschlag aus Bayern
der da übrigens ja auch gemacht wird
sind die stationären Grenzkontrollen sie
waren bisher nur für die Schleier
Verhandlung also Verdachts und Anlass
unabhängige Personenkontrolle haben sie
da ihre Meinung geändert also die
stationären Grenzkontrollen in zu
Österreich in Bayern hat nicht Herr
Söder angeordnet sondern ich insofern
sollte er jetzt auch nicht den gut
vermitteln er würde das tun
insofern finde ich gehört da wieder ein
bisschen mehr Sachlichkeit rein es ist
sehr wichtig dass wir an den Grenzen
auch zur Schweiz zu Tschechien Polen
dass wir tatsächlich hier Erfolge
hinbekommen und das geht im Moment
besser wenn man breiter an den Grenzen
kontrolliert das geht mit
Schleierfahndung besser als wenn man nur
wenige stationäre Grenzkontrollen hat
aber
völligationäre genau
heute im Bundestag gesagt wenn es zum
Beispiel im Wege der
schleuserbekämpfung der ich mich jetzt
auch noch mal sehr verstärkt angenommen
habe mal notwendig ist kurzfristig zu
schließen dann kann das ein Mittel sein
sie liegen Frau Feser in den Umfragen in
Hessen über zehn Prozentpunkte hinter
der CDU zurück was wenn Sie die Wahl
verlieren es könnte tatsächlich auch auf
ein historisch schlechte das historisch
schlechteste Ergebnis für die SPD
hinauslaufen bleiben sie Innenministerin
also noch sehen wir das in Bayern nicht
das in Hessen das Entschuldigung noch
sehen wir in Hessen natürlich noch nicht
dass dort ein historisch schlechtes
Ergebnis kommt wir liegen im Moment
deutlich hinten hinter der CDU das
stimmt wir liegen aber an zweiter Stelle
das in allen Umfragen und noch reden die
Menschen in Hessen nicht über Hessen es
wird sehr viel über Bund geredet aber
ich habe gefragt ob sie Innenministerin
bleiben selbst wenn sie die Wahl krachen
verlieren also ich habe immer gesagt ich
biete den Menschen in Hessen an
Ministerpräsidentin zu werden kandidiere
als solche Versuche ein möglichst
starkes Ergebnis für die SPD auch sehr
lang auf der anderen Seite habe ich hier
in Berlin sehr viel Verantwortung
übernommen für ein wichtiges Haus und
dem werde ich im Wege einer Niederlage
nachkommen
was auch immer das konkret dann heißt
Nancy fazer die Innenministerin vielen
herzlichen Dank für das Gespräch heute
herzlichen Dank Frau Herr Ali
und das Interview haben wir am frühen
Abend aufgezeichnet gestern haben wir
hier die Frage gestellt ob aus einer
Krise ein Krieg wird in Bergkarabach die
Antwort erstmal nicht denn die dortige
armenische Führung und Aserbaidschan
haben sich auf eine Feuerpause
verständigt am Morgen noch da saß nicht
danach aus denn also bei Jan setzte
seinen Militäreinsatz fort die Armenia
sollen dann aber kapituliert und
eingewilligt haben ihre Waffen abzugeben
am Abend sagte dann der Präsident
Aserbaidschans der Einsatz seiner
Truppen sei beendet und die Souveränität
seines Landes sei wieder hergestellt
der Konflikt zwischen Armenien und
Aserbaidschan um Bergkarabach der spielt
ja seit Jahrzehnten die Waffenruhe nach
dem letzten Krieg im Jahr 2020 die wurde
immer wieder gebrochen an den Körper in
Moskau daher heute die Frage Feuerpause
klingt ja gut aber wie sehr können sich
die Menschen insbesondere in
Bergkarabach darauf wirklich verlassen
ich denke das können sie nicht weil viel
zu viel unklar ist was wird denn mit den
Menschen dort passieren werden sie
davonlaufen werden sie vertrieben werden
oder werden sie vielleicht sich wehren
das ist heute Abend alles unklar das war
ein Tag der Gewinner und der Verlierer
in der Region und die Menschen zählen
definitiv zuletzt darin der
offensichtliche Gewinner ist dass er bei
Johns Präsident aliyef Sie haben es
gerade gesagt er hat den per
Fernsehansprache seinen Sieg verkündet
er hat den Zeitpunkt abgepasst dafür für
diese ganze Aktion wo als Armeniens
Partner verwundbar waren das ist
Russland das ist aber auch die
Europäische Union von dort hörte man
heute kleinlaut man da eben abhängig von
Gas aus Aserbaidschan zu denen die nicht
gewonnen haben seit Vladimir Putin er
musste er feiert sich zwar als
friedensvermittler musste aber der
Faktor alle Forderungen von
Aserbaidschan akzeptieren und er musste
eingestehen dass er damit nicht mehr der
Herrscher im Kaukasus ist das führt uns
zum Gewinner des tagesrezeptoren er hat
seine Machtsphäre und seine
Einflusssphäre ausgeweitet welche Folgen
das jetzt für die fragile
Sicherheitsarchitektur in Zentralasien
und Osteuropa hat inklusive der Ukraine
muss man sagen das ist heute Abend
überhaupt nicht absehbar alles in einem
äußerst kompliziert aber danke für deine
sehr gute Einordnung die man gut
verstehen konnte
und wir blicken jetzt erstmal nach New
York zur UNO Vollversammlung und da
wartet mir viele gespannt darauf ob sie
sich an einen Tisch setzen würden der
russische Außenminister und der
Präsident der Ukraine im
UN-Sicherheitsrat gondola ja und sie
trafen nicht aufeinander der russische
Außenminister kam erst nach silenskys
Rede in den UN-Sicherheitsrat dabei
Beklagte der ukrainische Präsident die
Machtlosigkeit der Vereinten Nationen
sie agierten mit Rhetorik statt mit
echten Lösungen
selensky drängte auf grundlegende
Reformen und verlangte eine Mechanismus
um Vetos im Sicherheitsrat zu überwinden
außerdem plädierte er für mehr
Mitglieder in dem Gremium darunter
Deutschland
selensky verließ den Rat bevor kam der
wiederum machte erneut den Westen für
die Spannungen verantwortlich
UN-Generalsekretär gut hat den Menschen
gemacht beachten Klimawandel für die
extremen Hitzewellen und Waldbrände
dieses Jahres verantwortlich gemacht
durch ihre klimaschädlichen Aktivitäten
habe die Menschheit das Tor zur Hölle
geöffnet sagte
uterisch zu Eröffnung eines Klimagipfels
am Rande der un-generaldebatte es sei
aber noch nicht zu spät die Zukunft zu
gestalten und den globalen
Temperaturanstieg zu begrenzen
unterstrich der UN-Generalsekretär
großbritannien will dagegen seine
Klimapolitik lockern premier suneck
erklärte der bisher eingeschlagene Kurs
Bürde britischen Familien zu hohe Kosten
auf so solle etwa das Verkaufsverbot für
neue Diesel und Benzinfahrzeuge fünf
Jahre später als geplant erst 25 in
Kraft treten am Ziel Klimaneutralität
ist 2050 will Zune aber festhalten
Gina Massa Amini ist Kostüm für den
Sacharow-Preis des EU-Parlaments
nominiert worden der Tod der 22-jährigen
vor einem Jahr hatte massive Proteste im
Iran ausgelöst Amini war in
Polizeigewahrsam gestorben wegen
angeblicher Verstöße gegen die Kopftuch
Pflicht war sie festgenommen worden
zugleich hat das iranische Parlament
eine Verschärfung der Strafen bei
Verstößen gegen die Kopftuchpflicht
beschlossen im Extremfall bis zu 15
Jahre Haft viele Frauen im Iran tragen
seit dem Tod aminis ganz bewusst kein
Kopftuch mehr
ja und wir Hoffnung hatte dass sich
durch diese Proteste die es ja seit über
einem Jahren ja in Iran gibt dort groß
etwas ändert möglicherweise das Land
sogar demokratische Züge bekommt der
sieht sich enttäuscht dabei wäre eine
andere Führung eine andere Politik nicht
nur für die Menschen im Land sondern
auch über die Grenzen hinaus von enormer
Bedeutung denn Iran schickt Drohnen zur
Unterstützung Putins nach Russland
mischt sich in irakische Angelegenheiten
ein mischt auch in Syrien mit steht an
der Seite der Hisbollah im Libanon ist
zudem eine ständige Bedrohung für Israel
und unterstützt die hutti Rebellen im
Jemen aber Iran denkt gar nicht daran
sich zurückzunehmen im Gegenteil er
schwärmt sogar die Prüfung seiner
Atomanlagen und rückt enger an China und
Russland heran
Überleben in der Krise auf der großen
Kunststoffmesse in Teheran kann man in
diesen Tagen sehen wie das geht wenn der
Westen mit seinen Sanktionen die Türen
zuschlägt machen andere ihre Türen weit
auf chinesische Firmen sind hier
allgegenwärtig beliefern Iran mit ihren
Maschinen schon heute ist China einer
der größten Handelspartner
irgendwie in der Zukunft erwarte ich
dass der Markt für unsere Produkte in
Iran weiter sehr stark wachsen wird
die chinesische Staatsführung will im
Mittleren Osten eine größere Rolle
spielen Iran vom Westen wirtschaftlich
unabhängig werden so vermittelte China
die historische Annäherung zwischen den
Erzfeinden Iran und Saudi Arabien China
förderte den Beitritt Irans zur
Vereinigung der Schwellenländer Brix im
August vorher bereits war Iran dem
Shanghai Kooperationsrat beigetreten dem
auch China und Russland angehören
in diesem Sinne hat das islamische
Regime einen Sieg eingefahren es hat
sich gestärkt durch engere Beziehungen
zu Russland und zu China
das gilt auch für Ölgeschäft Iran
verkauft so viel Öl an China wie nie und
will wie die anderen Schwellenländer
auch seine Geschäfte möglichst nicht den
US-Dollar abwickeln dafür sagen Experten
braucht es neue Partner
ein Land dessen Wirtschaftsleistung
immer noch geringer ist als die seiner
regionalen Konkurrenten kann es allein
nicht schaffen voraussetzung sind
bessere Außenbeziehungen und
internationale Zusammenarbeit
Zusammenarbeit auch zwischen
international geächteten Besuch des
russischen
Verteidigungsministers heute in Tehran
es geht um Rüstungsgeschäfte und
militärische Zusammenarbeit
wir wollen eine ganze Reihe gemeinsamer
Aktivitäten beschließen trotz der
Ablehnung durch die USA und ihrer
westlichen Alliierten der Druck der
Sanktionen auf Russland und Iran ist
vergeblich
dieser Druck kann tatsächlich gut fürs
Geschäft sein so macht er iranische
Folienhersteller Ratter Plast beste
Umsätze ohne Kunden aus dem Westen nach
Beginn dieses bedauerlichen Krieges
zwischen Russland und Ukraine sind die
Wirtschaftsbeziehungen zwischen Russland
und Iran täglich besser geworden heute
kommen die meisten unserer Kunden aus
Russland
ob Wirtschaftsunternehmen oder die
politische Führung Irans beide suchen
und finden neue Geschäftspartner um zu
überleben in der Krise
und damit schauen wir jetzt auf Proteste
die es heute bei uns in einigen
deutschen Städten gab es geht um
Krankenhäuser um die
Versorgungssicherheit und Arbeitsplätze
oder kurzum es geht ganz einfach ums
Geld die Inflation Schmerz da hilft dann
auch kein Pflaster mehr und angeblich
könnten im nächsten Jahr knapp 80% der
Kliniken gute Zahlen schreiben die
Lösung so richtig ist erstmal keine in
Sicht auch weil Bund und Länder mal
wieder mit dem Finger auf den jeweils
anderen zeigen ritterspiekermann
unverzichtbar das ist Mahnung und
Kampfansage zugleich medizinisches
Personal aus dem ganzen Land ist
angereist die Wut macht sich Luft am
Brandenburger Tor Corona war schon
schwer für sie jetzt die finanzielle Not
ihrer Kliniken und ganz viel Angst
unsere Forderung ist dass die Politik
relativ schnell ein sofortpaket und ist
unkontrollierte Sterben von
Krankenhäusern zu verhindern
andere Form ist eine fast für uns das
ist eine geschleichende
krankenhauslandschaftsbereinigung aus
unserer Sicht wir brauchen Kohle mehr
als das Kohle Kohle Kohle so fordert es
anders ausgedrückt auch die Deutsche
Krankenhausgesellschaft sieht die
Kliniken in einer insolvenzelle wirklich
greifen werde die Reform erst 2027 für
viele Kliniken komme sie zu spät wir
wehren uns gegen einen kalten
Strukturwandel wir wären uns dagegen das
Krankenhäuser schließen müssen aus
wirtschaftlicher Notlage heraus weil man
uns einen Inflationsausgleich verwehrt
weil man uns mit den Kosten alleine
lässt das Klinikum Gütersloh in
Nordrhein-Westfalen steckt in den roten
Zahlen vier Millionen Euro Defizit ist
die Prognose für 2023 gab es für
Energiekosten Ausgleichszahlungen
drücken vor allem hohe Personalkosten
und die Inflation auf die Bilanz
Situation ist für uns beklemmt gerade
unter dem Aspekt das jetzt schon 40
Kliniken bundesweit in Insolvenz
gegangen sind was meiner Sicht ist das
unkontrolliert und damit ist auch die
Versorgungssicherheit die wir in
Deutschland als selbstverständlich
erachten nicht mehr gewährleistet
Minister Lauterbach will mit weniger
Kliniken mehr Qualität sichern das ist
sein Versprechen unumgänglich aus seiner
Sicht der Abbau von Überkapazitäten
Problem ist die Kliniken füllen sich
nicht mehr wir haben so viele klingen
wir haben ja die höchste klinikdichte in
ganz Europa sind nicht die Fälle und ist
auch nicht das Personal da um 1700
Krankenhäuser mit hoher Qualität zu
betreiben und verweist darauf dass die
Länder entscheiden müssten welche Klinik
überlebt und welche nicht es ist ein
schmerzhafter Schwebezustand für
Personal und Patienten
wichtiges Thema und bei uns später dann
im heute-journal Update dazu dann auch
ein Gespräch mit dem
Vorstandsvorsitzenden der Deutschen
Krankenhausgesellschaft Gerald Gass und
hier geht es jetzt erstmal weiter mit
Gundula und Meldungen aus der Wirtschaft
die Finanzmärkte haben an diesem
Mittwoch mit Spannung auf eine
anstehende Zinsentscheidung der
US-Notenbank Fett gewartet und die kam
um 20 Uhr wie erwartet die Währungshüter
lassen ihre Zinsen unverändert bei der
Spanne von
5,25 bis
5,5%. zugleich gehen die Erzeugerpreise
in Deutschland in hohempo zurück sie
fielen im August im Jahresvergleich um
12,6 Prozent so deutlich wie noch nie
seit Beginn der Erhebungen valeriehalle
an der Börse wie erklärt sich das und
was heißt das für die weitere
Preisentwicklung nur die
Herstellerpreise fallen so drastisch
weil sie im Jahr zuvor aufgrund des
Ukraine Krieges im Rekordtempo gestiegen
waren statistischer
Basis Effekt also die preisschocks sind
ja auch erstmal überwunden spürbar
günstiger geworden ist Energie Strom
sogar um 43 Prozent Nahrungsmittel
hingegen bleiben teuer Zucker kostete im
August sogar 87 Prozent mehr ein
gemischtes Bild also aber unterm Strich
nimmt der Preisdruck im Gewerbe ab das
heißt es müsste damit auch zu einer
weiteren Abschwächung der immer noch
hohen Inflation kommen das ist richtig
die Chancen steigen zumindest dass die
hartnäckige Inflation sich langsam
abschwächt die Erzeugerpreise sind ja
sozusagen ein Vorbote für die
Verbraucherpreise ein Warnsignal jedoch
ist der Ölpreis der zuletzt wieder
gestiegen ist und sich auf einem
mehrmonatigen hoch bewegt auch steigen
die Löhne schätzungen zufolge sollen sie
kommen des Jahr sogar deutlich anziehen
viele Ökonomen gehen davon aus dass die
Inflation in den kommenden Monaten
nachlässt allzu große Sprünge darf man
aber vermutlich nicht da warten vielen
Dank Valerie für die Einschätzung
die Folgen von Kinderarmut machen sich
in deutschen Klassenzimmern immer
stärker bemerkbar das ist das Ergebnis
einer Umfrage der Robert Bosch Stiftung
die heute zum Weltkindertag vorgestellt
wurde fast ein Drittel der Lehrkräfte
beobachtet demnach Schüler die ohne
Frühstück in die Schule kommen oder nur
unzureichende Schulmaterial besitzen
besonders häufig nahmen Lehrkräfte
Konzentrationsprobleme bei Schülern warm
die zweifache DDR Olympiasiegerin im
Speerwurf rutfuchs ist im Alter von 76
Jahren in Jena gestorben ihr erstes Gold
gewann sie 1972 in München vier Jahre
später dann in Montreal als erste Frau
warf sie den Speer weiter als 60 Meter
später gab sie offen zu gedopt zu haben
nach ihrer Sportkarriere ging sie in die
Politik saß in der Volkskammer im
Bundestag und im Landtag von Thüringen
für die Linke
in der Fußball Champions League war
Union Berlin am Abend zu Gast bei Real
Madrid einige Hundert der 4.000
angereisten Berliner Fans kamen
allerdings zunächst nicht ins Stadion
wegen Problemen bei den
Einlasskontrollen das Spiel gewann real
sehr spät mit 1:0 alles vom ersten
Champions League Spieltag um 23 Uhr hier
im ZDF Sportstudio und wir haben die
gewinnzahlen vom Lotto am Mittwoch sie
lauten drei
1821 24 33 42 Superzahl 2 weitere
Gewinnzahlen auf Lotto zdf.de und im ZDF
Text auf Seite 557
es ist ein royaler Besuch mit Verspätung
Großbritanniens König Charles und seine
Frau Camilla sind in Frankreich um die
Freundschaft bei der Länder zu stärken
die nach dem brexit Spannungen
ausgesetzt ist in Paris gedachte Charles
gemeinsam mit Präsident macron der Toten
bei der Weltkriege der dreitägige
Staatsbesuch war für März geplant und
musste wegen der Proteste gegen macrons
Rentenreform verschoben werden zur
Stunde gibt es auf Schloss Versailles
ein Staatsbankett mit mehr als 150
Gästen
dann haben die gar nicht das heute schon
mal geguckt komisch so auf den krönenden
Abschluss folgt jetzt hier das
auslandsjournal dort sehen Sie unter
anderem eine Reportage über
Sonderermittler in der Ukraine die sich
auf die Spur von Kriegsverbrechern
gemacht haben und gegen 0 Uhr ist hier
wieder Zeit für unser heute journal
Update mit Nazan guckte mir das war's
von uns beiden machen sie es gut wo auch
immer sie sind tschüss
[Musik]
schönen guten Abend und herzlich
willkommen zum Wetter der ehemalige
Hurrikan Lee hat mittlerweile die
britischen Inseln erreicht dazu gehört
eine Kaltfront und die erreicht uns
morgen bringt Regen und Gewitter mit
davor wird hier ordentlich warme Luft
herangeführt vor allem im Osten
Deutschlands steigen die Temperaturen
kräftig an und der Kratzen an der 30
Grad Marke schauen wenn die Nacht und da
gibt's vor allem im Süden Nebel in
Gewässer Nähe an meinen und Donau z.B
ansonsten gratis häufig auf und die
Temperaturen gehen zurück bis auf 9 Grad
hier Richtung Vogtland und 18 Grad ganz
im Westen am Niederrhein häufig Werte um
die 15 Grad Marke es ist also noch eine
relativ milde Nacht morgen dann erst
einmal fast überall Sonnenschein auch im
Westen dann verdichtet sich hier die
bewölkerung Regen kommt auf Schauer sind
dabei und einzelne Gewittern das ganze
verlagert sich bis zum Abend dann
natürlich in die Mitte Deutschlands ganz
im Osten und im Südosten merkt man wenig
davon da scheint verbreitet die Sonne
Temperaturen dazu höchste Werte bis 29
Grad hier Richtung Berlin und 20 Grad in
der Eifel also nochmal ein richtig
warmer Tag aber in den nächsten Tagen
geht es deutlich wechselhafter und
kühler weiter viel Regen am Freitag bei
14 bis 21 Grad Samstag im Osten
zeitweise trockensonntag dann verbreitet
trocken bei 14 bis 22 Grad und damit ein
schöner Abend